Santo Domingo llegada recepción y
encuentro 13 jefes de estado y
representación de 22 países de América
Latina y la Península ibérica esto no ha
impedido que el presidente de Chile
Gabriel boric se refiriese a si a
Nicaragua con representación en la
Cumbre no es acep
Table de parte
nuestro que acaba de privar de su
nacionalidad a 94 opositores y deportar
a más de 200 presos políticos que la
patria se lleva en el alma y en la
sangre y no secreta no se quita por
decreto
las decisiones en la Cumbre se toman por
consenso por lo que se necesita de
equilibrios para llegar a acuerdos Como
por ejemplo ha sido el caso de la
cooperación derechos digitales seguridad
alimentaria y sobre todo el pacto verde
esas proyecciones que hacen los
científicos
si no se hace nada
hace de buena parte de este espacio
geográfico que aquí se reúne un lugar
inhabilitado en la tierra para el año
nuestros nietos en el año 2070 no
podrían vivir en nuestros países
el anfitrión República Dominicana
también ha tenido espacio en su discurso
para Haití
situación en Haití los que están
sufriendo son los pobres haitianos los
pocos ricos están en Miami o aquí en
República Dominicana
y todos los días con esas bandas lo que
hay es violaciones y más violaciones a
todos los derechos humanos y violaciones
también
con menos fama que otras Cumbres la
iberoamericanas se consolida con la
número 28 desde 1991 mientras que ya
está confirmada la próxima cita será en
Ecuador en noviembre de 2024